[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bonjour nicolas bonjour
justin alors est ce que tu sais où on
est aujourd'hui tu m'a amené au
bréviaire fois un an exactement écoutons
néo bréviaire sur la communauté
d'agglomération de rambouillet
territoire et plus précisément aux
étangs de hollande alors tu m'as dit
d'amener mes affaires de plage rouge
d'etzella mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
en fait alors en fait écoutent ils ont
rouvert depuis juin ici à plein de
choses à faire plein d'activités il ya
du mini golf il ya du ping pong il ya
même de la restauration du canoë kayak
et j'ai une petite surprise pour toi
justement on va les faire tout de suite
mais avant je te propose comme il fait
chaud qu'on aille se changer on va se
changer puis j'ai toutes les affaires là
dedans on n'oublie pas la crème solaire
parce qu'il fait chaud quand même à tout
de suite
[Musique]
voilà nous on est fin prêt pour profiter
de la journée g20 mais nicolas profiter
de sa surprise en attendant on a
rencontré thomas gourland ou alors
thomas goût relancer le président de
rambouillet territoire la communauté
d'agglomération qui gère cette base de
loisirs et il nous présente justement ce
parent
[Musique]
les torts de l'homme en fait c'est très
très vieille histoire puisque ces étangs
été créée sous louis xiv pour alimenter
les autres versailles est donc cet étang
en fait il n'est pas alimentée par une
rivière et l'alimenté simplement par le
réseau depuis donc il faut qu'il pleuve
pour qu'on ait de l'eau l'été sur les
gros ce week-end on voit les gens
arrivent et du 95 du 77 donc on revient
de très loin et voir aussi quelquefois
des centres de loisirs de la région
centre qui viennent aussi passé une
journée chez nous 6900 entré depuis le
1er juin depuis l'ouverture on est à 10
% d'augmentation par rapport à l'année
dernière donc une vraie attractivité
voilà nicolas on arrivait battant je
vois des embarcations c'est un pédalo
nom s'est dit pédalo on va les faire du
pédalo est ce que tu es prêt ouais je
suis prêt aussi perd on va se préparer
alors ça va être sportif exactement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon nicolas c'est parti parti est bien
installé je suis très bien l'installer
cactus et pédaler parce que je vais pas
tout faire non non t'inquiète je te
prête assistance quand même
là pour faire avancer à nicolas en vue
de recul et un on avance allez allez on
avance allez c'est parti pour que tu
suives le rythme justin tu as perdu par
contre quelqu'un pied de la barre ce don
va tourner et un nicolas bon justin tuba
alors barré c'est bien évidemment
orienté le pédalo mais j'ai l'impression
que justin s'en sort plutôt bien j'ai
apprécié qu'on n'avance pas beaucoup
nicolas quand même hein on va accélérer
tu veux accélérer mais face à une
activité dont quand même on veut
profiter tranquillement
à part la en plus regardées à l'avant du
pédalo vous pouvez vous poser ça c'est
pour ceux qui sont pas trop sportif quoi
regarder ou derrière justin on a
l'impression que on va assez vite quand
même c'est une impression je te rassure
on est qu
on apprend à faire le tour de l'étang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était trop bien merci justin écoute là
on n'a pas tout fait on aurait pu aussi
faire du canoë kayak pouvait aller se
baigner est ce qu'on te propose c'est
qu'on aille voir comment ça se passe sur
place et on va voir ça avec basile
kadiki et nageurs sauveteurs aux étangs
de hollande
vous pouvez vous baigner dans la zone
délimitée donc on a le petit bain qui a
90 cm de profondeur et le grand bain qui
à deux mètres cinquante ou trois mètres
quand il pleut fréquentation maximale
instantanée ici et à 2512 âgées s'il ya
plus de 30 personnes le lot on doit être
à 5 en surveillance et quand on
s'approche des 2000 personnes on est
sept voire huit
[Musique]
oui
oh
c'est
franchement justine une matinée génial
le pédalo c'était trop bien et c'était
trop bien et après l'effort parce qu'on
a vraiment bien travaillé le réconfort
cuisine antillaise exactement on a
trouvé donc un petit fou de truck voilà
j'ai directement à côté de l'étang en
fait exactement comme ça on voyage en
plus en même temps c'est génial ça a
l'air bon hein un beau quitte alors
c'est un sandwich antilles et
spécialités antillaises des patates
douces et puis des acras de morue les
acras de morue t'es peut-être finir avec
ça alors non pas du tout tu vois bon bah
tu vas pouvoir goûter à l'or bah oui
très bien et puis des petites boissons
que toi je sais pas c'est pas évident
que ce que tu as eue c'est ça c'est une
boisson à la fleur d'hibiscus moi j'ai
eu ananas et un homme assez gingembre
aux
écoutes santé bon bah tchin tchin et
puis ben on va manger tout ça on va se
régaler je pense
[Musique]
et
je trouve ça sympa il ya un peu moins de
monde qu'à la mer - devant l'ambiance
est plutôt sympa c'est bien sécurisé
pour les enfants donc plutôt cool parce
que on préfère
cet espace plutôt que la piscine en off
un pique nique on a nagé et puis
maintenant on est passé aux jeux de
raquettes l'on était en vacances chez
les grands parents qui habitent dans la
vallée heureuse et puis on cherchait un
endroit où se baigner donc bon de
regarder un petit peu sur internet est
le plus proche de château fond c'était
les étangs de long je suis vignes et
j'ai fait des châteaux de sable
on a petit look et
on nage ou raquettes au vallon
[Musique]
bon justin le pédalo c'était très bien
ce matin tu m'as parlé du minigolf allez
je prends le club mais tu vas prendre
une raclée taux courants ouais je sais
ouais d'accord c'est juste pour te
prévenir on verra d'ailleurs belge une
balle jaune allez je commence à laisser
partir de commencer
[Musique]
bon justin deux coups sur le premier
trou je m'incline merci nicolas j'ai
gagné je pense que oui bon écoute je
dirai pas combien de coups tu l'as fait
un peu ses gammes le plus facile en a
beaucoup et tu l'as fait en huit coups
voilà je les dis
combien de parcours ya là voilà il ya 18
trous en fait on a fait deux ou trois
ans mini web c'était plutôt pas mal moi
j'ai plutôt apprécié je pense qu'on
enchaîne avec une dernière petite
activité pour la journée une petite je
fais tant que c'était sa passion la
pétanque c'est parti bon c'est parti m
par an dans le sud à l'est
la journée touche à sa fin merci justin
pour cette journée hausse étant de
hollande c'était génial merci à tanis
colonne s'est bien amusé donc les
informations pratiques si on souhaite
revenir exactement nous pour les
informations pratiques il faut savoir
que les stands et hollande sont ouverts
jusqu'au 31 août 5 jours par semaine du
mercredi au dimanche de 11h 30 à 19
heures et puis pour tout ce qui est
activités et renseignements pour elle et
sur le site de rambouillet territoire
notamment pour savoir quelles activités
sont payantes et quelles activités vous
pouvez comme la pour la pétanque ou le
ping pong comme nous ramenez vos
affaires c'est ça c'est gratuit et puis
ben voila j'ai les boules j'ai le
cochonnet c'est parti et partir on n'a
plus qu'à vous souhaiter un bel été sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon unique au studio tu pointes je vais
pointer 10 partir
m
[Musique]